just as truth tables provide a simply
direct way to define the meanings of the
individual propositional connectives or
propositional operators they also
provide a methodical way to understand
the behavior of formulas and in
particular whether the two formulas are
equivalent or whether a formula is valid
meaning that it's always true so let's
take a look at that to begin with if I'm
thinking about a proposition with a warm
ela it's a composite one that's built
out of lots of more atomic primitive
ones then in order to figure out the
value of the whole thing I need to know
the values of the individual components
so if we think of a formula involving
P's and Q's and ours that are true false
value propositional variables then I
need a truth assignment to know the
values of those variables in order to
know whether or not the formula is true
or false so in computer science jargon
this process of assigning values to
variables is called an environment
logicians would call it a truth
assignment so an environment it tells
you given a variable whether or not it's
true or false let's look at an example
of three variables P Q and R they're
true/false value and I'm going to tell
you that this I've got an environment V
in which P is true and Q is true and R
is false so V of P is teh etcetera and
so I'm thinking of V as a function that
map's a variable to its value now let's
see how I would use this particular
environment to figure out the value of
this composite formula whose atomic
parts are P and Q and R and and and Q
again okay let's take a look at how we
would go about figuring out the value of
this whole formula given the values of P
Q it's pretty straightforward but the
methodical way to do it is sort of from
inside out let's begin by a by attaching
the truth values that were given to
those particular variables okay now
notice here that I've got both arms of
the and have been assigned truth values
and they're both true that means I can
assign true to the conjunct
the end formula and I put I do that by
putting the tea under that and which is
the principle connective of this sub
formula now looking back at this queue
I've got it's true which means that not
of Q is false and so I can put a false
under than not now notice I've got both
arms of this XOR are defined they're
both false that means that the XOR is
false because it's only supposed to be
true if exactly one of them is true and
next I had this true for n that means
that naught of that formula is false and
now that I have both arms of the or this
one is false and that one is false I can
conclude that the entire expression is
false
by putting that final truth value under
the principle connective of the whole
formula so that's actually an easily
defined recursive process I've described
it from inside out but if you were
programming it on you would be doing it
recursively top-down in order to
evaluate the truth value of a formula
given the truth values of its
constituent variables given an
environment now a basic idea about
propositional formulas is two of them
are normally if and only if they have
the same truth values in all
environments in all environments no
matter what the values of the of the P's
and Q's in our zone no matter what the
truth value is these two formulas come
out to the same Twitter that's what
makes them equivalent let's look at an
important example you know as de
Morgan's law so de Morgan's law says
that if I look at this formula the knot
of P or Q the cut the negation of P or Q
I claim that that's equivalent to not P
and not Q and let's check that with the
truth table
okay so here's going to be the truth
table for the first formula not P or Q
so let's write out the four possible
values for P and Q these are the four
possible environments one per row and
there is the formula for the whose value
I'm trying to compute so we do it in the
usual way I'm not going to repeat the
truth values of P and Q because they're
given here but I can fill in the values
of the or
because I know the truth tango 4 or and
I discovered that the first three rows
this sub or sub formulas during the last
place is false when both of them are
false that means that I know the value
of the whole formula which is the
negation the not of all those values
just flips the trues and falses and that
is the final truth values for this not p
or q in all possible environments let's
do the same thing for not P and not Q
well this time I'll fill in the values
have not P and not Q because they're not
just repeated there so they are so that
not P is the flip of the PE column and
the not Q is the flip of the Q column
and now I can fill in the values of the
and and of course the end is going to be
true only when they're both true and
otherwise it's going to be false and
look what I've got the possible truth
values of the first formula not P or Q
in all possible environments is exactly
the same as the possible truth values of
not P and not Q in those corresponding
environments the columns are the same
and that means these two formulas are
equivalent which is the proof by truth
table we've just examined all possible
environments and verified that in fact
they get the same truth value this
brings us to a useful other connective
we haven't talked about yet called if
and only if so the value of the if and
only if connective P if and only if Q is
true if and only if P and Q have the
same truth value know this if and only
if is an English word that you're
supposed to understand what it means and
that if and only if is an operator on
truth values that we're defining this
since the English not going to be
confusing between that if and only if an
S if and only if let's disambiguate by
having the truth table for if and only
if here it is what it says is that when
both of them are true P if and only if Q
is true and both of them are false P if
and only if Q is true and otherwise it's
false you can check that P if and only
if is true Oh exactly when the
complement of px or Q is true so now we
come to two crucial properties of
formulas called satis
viability and validity and let's examine
what those are so a formula is
satisfiable if and only if it's true in
some environment that is its satisfiable
if there's some way to set the values of
the variables P and Q to be truth values
in such a way that the formula comes out
to be true and a related idea is that
our formula is valid it's also called a
tautology if and only if it's true in
all environments no matter what you set
the variables to it's gonna come out to
be true let's look at some examples to
solidify those two concepts so the
formula P all by itself is satisfiable
because it can be true if P is true but
it's not always true those P might be
false
symmetrically not P is also satisfiable
because it can be true if P is false but
it's not always true it's not valid
because P might be true in which case
not many will be false to formulas a
formula it's not satisfying all the
formulas means that there is no truth
value that makes it true which is the
same as saying that it's always false is
the formula P and not P it's probably
the simplest not satisfiable formula or
unsatisfiable formula so this is clearly
false because either P or not P has got
to be false in the end well then we'll
definitely come out to be false there
was no value of 4p that makes this
formula true it's unsatisfiable a valid
formula actually bite the Morgan's law
applied to the P and not P is P or not P
is gonna be valid because no matter what
truth value P has it comes out to be
true that is one of P and not P is true
and therefore the or is gonna get at
least one true exactly one true really
and gonna come out to be true so this is
valid now we can connect up the pieces
that we've just set up of related
relating validity and equivalence two
formulas GNH are equivalent is the same
as saying that g if and only if h is
valid so g if and only if h comes out to
be true when g and h have the same truth
value
and G&H are equivalent says that they do
have the same truth value no matter what
no matter what the environment is so
that's the same as saying that if G and
H are equivalent no matter what the
environment is G if and only if H comes
out to be true
so if G and H are equivalent G if and
only if H is valid and the converse
argument works the same way a very
important problem that comes up in
multiple ways and we're going to examine
some of them later is the problem of
whether or not a formula is valid
checking that or proving that it's valid
and checking whether or not a formula is
satisfiable now there's a simple way to
do that the truth table tells it to you
if you want to know whether the formula
is satisfiable you just look at its
truth table try every possible
environment and see whether one of the
meals the value true the problem with
that approach which theoretically is
sound like pragmatically the truth table
size doubles with each additional
variable so with two variables you've
got four rows with three variables you
got eight roles with four variables
you've got sixteen rows and this very
rapidly gets out of hand once the number
of variables gets to be moderate-sized
this is exponential growth it's doubling
each time you add a variable so really
when you start having hundreds of
variables truth tables are out of the
question you just can't write them down
they're too big and in fact in modern
digital circuits when you think back
about how we designed the adder if you
look at what's going on and all those
different wires corresponding to
different truth out for different
variables there are millions of those in
a typical modern digital circuit so
truth table approach is just not going
to be work work of all it's hopeless now
one of the central problems in
theoretical computer science is the
question of whether or not there is a
way to test for Sat that's more
efficient than this impossible way of
trying to come up with a truth table
that's too big to fit in the universe
when there are hundreds and thousands of
variables so we're interested in the
question isn't there some other way to
check a formula for satisfiability then
exhaustively trying to generate it so
it's whole truth table to see if some
row yields
this is the abstract version of the P
equals NP problem so we've talked about
this before P equals NP question mark is
the considered to be the most important
open problem in theoretical computer
science in the theory of computation and
it's simply saying is there some fast or
efficient way to solve to tell whether
or not a formula is satisfiable that's
more efficient than the truth table
approach efficiency has a technical
definition which is that the number of
steps in rows
much less than exponentially with the
number of variables let's say it grows
polynomial like a quadratic or a cubic
but you're trying to beat exponential
growth which is what ruins things
quickly and this is an open problem no
one knows if there is some fast way to
check for satisfiability or saat that's
the sad problem by the way we're very
closely related to statins validity
because if I wanted to know whether a
formula G is valid
well valine means that it's always true
that means its complement not G is
always false which is the same as saying
its complement is not satisfiable so to
check that G is valid all I need to do
is check that not G is satisfiable and
of it it's not satisfiable and
vice-versa
not G is not satisfiable if and only if
G is valid so the point is that sat and
valid stand and fall together if you had
a fast way to do one you would very
quickly get a fast way to do the other
one so checking for one is just as
difficult as checking for the other and
we're going to examine in subsequent
lectures why it is that this problem is
so important